that is the Angel of the North Anthony
Gormley's incredible sculpture that
stands as one of the icons of modern
Britain but angels aren't all like that
at least not in Christian philosophy
pseudo-dionysius the areopagite and I'm
probably mispronouncing that and know
that wasn't the name we went by then was
a Christian writer in the 5th and 6th
centuries and he along with Thomas
Aquinas settled on the modern Christian
hierarchy of angels and my word if you
wanted terrifying creatures you need
look no further than angels because yes
the ones in the lower orders they look
vaguely humanoid as the term would be
now but up at the top hole you have the
cherubim and they're not cherubs in the
sense of angelic well yes angelic little
children with serene expressions no they
have four heads a man a lion an eagle
and an ox and then then you have the
Thrones and the Thrones they don't like
that gorgeous thing they look like a
wheel within a wheel covered in EIU's
seriously if you wanted terrifying
creatures and science fiction it turns
out you can just go and look at some
angels this angel on the other hand is a
lot prettier a lot nicer and frankly
even though I'm not religious this is a
greater testament to God's work than any
wheel within wheels with eyes on it from
the angel the North that is something
you might not have known one more thing
before I go thank you very much to
everyone who replied to my call for help
a couple of days ago I got an order of
magnitude more answers than I thought I
would so you're all amazing thank you so
much I'm sorry if I didn't get to your
comment I did the best I could
oh and one more thing if you want a
bonus fact there's as much of that angel
below the ground as there is above 20
meters also down to the bedrock
otherwise while the wind might just make
it fly away